good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight a remarkable day
brett kavanaugh has stepped away from
the microphone in the senate hearing
room
he spent three and a half hours there it
was a remarkable moment
stunning in many ways like without
precedent in the lifetimes of many who
watched it
until this afternoon kavanaugh had
struck many who watched him as
bookish and academic the classic
temperament of a federal judge
he emerged though this afternoon
transformed a man
on fire fighting with everything he had
to save his family
himself and the presumption of innocence
kavanaugh began his testimony today with
an unequivocal denial of the allegations
against him
i did not sexually assault christine
blasey ford or anyone else at any time
he said
his voice rising the charges are false
but then kavanaugh did something
entirely unexpected he broadened his
response
and he aimed it directly at the senate
democrats sitting before him
this confirmation process has become a
national disgrace
the constitution gives the senate an
important role
in the confirmation process but you have
replaced
advice and consent with search and
destroy
since my nomination in july there's been
a frenzy
on the left to come up with something
anything
to block my confirmation shortly after i
was nominated the democratic senate
leader said he would quote
oppose me with everything he's got
a democratic senator on this committee
publicly
publicly referred to me as evil
evil think about that word
and said that those who supported me
were quote complicit in evil
another democratic senator on this
committee said
quote judge kavanaugh is your worst
nightmare
a former head of the democratic national
committee said
quote judge kavanaugh will threaten the
lives of millions
of americans for decades to come
i understand the passions of the moment
but i would say to those senators
your words have meaning millions of
americans listened carefully to you
given comments like those is it any
surprise
that people have been willing to do
anything
to make any physical threat against my
family
to send any violent email to my wife
to make any kind of allegation against
me and against my friends
to blow me up and take me down
you sowed the wind
for decades to come i fear that the
whole country
will reap the whirlwind
no supreme court nominee has spoken like
this in memory not even clarence thomas
but then none has been accused more
recklessly or with less
evidence than brett kavanaugh has and he
did nothing to hide his rage
this whole two-week effort has been a
calculated and orchestrated political
hit
fueled with apparent pent-up anger about
president trump
and the 2016 election
fear that has been unfairly stoked about
my judicial record
revenge on behalf of the clintons
and millions of dollars in money from
outside
left-wing opposition groups
this is a circus the consequences will
extend
long past my nomination the consequences
will be with us for decades
this grotesque and coordinated character
assassination
will dissuade competent and good people
of all political persuasions from
serving our country
and as we all know in the united states
political system of the early 2000s
what goes around comes around
i am an optimistic guy i always try to
be on the sunrise side of the mountain
to be optimistic about the day that is
coming but today
i have to say that i fear for the future
though throughout the hearing he
categorically denied her claims about
him kavanaugh showed no animus
personally toward christine ford
instead in one of the most riveting
moments of the day he explained how his
family had prayed for her
i'm not questioning that dr ford
may have been sexually assaulted by some
person
in some place at some time
but i have never done this to her
or to anyone that's not who i am
it is not who i was i am innocent of
this charge
i intend no ill will to dr ford
and her family the other night ashley
and my daughter eliza said their prayers
and little liza all 10 years old
said to ashley we should pray for the
woman
it's a lot of wisdom from a 10 year old
we mean we mean no ill will
behind him as he spoke brett kavanaugh's
mother wept with emotion
cavanaugh concluded his remarks today as
he begun them
defiantly i will not be intimidated into
withdrawing from this process
you've tried hard you've given it your
all
no one can question your effort but your
coordinated and well funded effort to
destroy
my good name and destroy my family
will not drive me out the vile threats
of violence
against my family will not drive me out
you may defeat me in the final vote
but you'll never get me to quit never
democrats in the room seem stunned by
kavanaugh's remarks and for a moment
they seem thrown back on their heels
but not for long ranking member dianne
feinstein began the questioning for
democrats
she seemed to suggest that kavanaugh was
secretly a sexual predator
reading from a script feinstein referred
to a woman called julie swetnick
who was a college student in suburban
washington when brett kavanaugh was in
high school
yesterday as we told you swetnick
claimed that she witnessed at least
10 public gang rapes in which brett
kavanaugh was supposedly present and
participating
it was a remarkable charge and yet
feinstein never mentioned that part of
swetnick's claim why is that
well because the story is ridiculous it
clashes with common sense it is lunatic
nobody believes it so feinstein let that
left that part out in order to smear
kavanaugh in front of the world
and omitted highly relevant information
about his accuser indeed the entire
accusation
it was reprehensibly dishonest behavior
especially for u.s senator
and kavanaugh all but said so
i'm talking about getting the evidence
and having the evidence looked at and
i don't understand
you know we hear from the witnesses
um but the fbi isn't interviewing them
and isn't giving us any facts so all we
have
you're interviewing me you're
interviewing me you're
you're doing it senator i'm sorry to
interrupt but you're doing it that's
the there's no conclusions reached and
and what you're saying
if if i understand it is that the
allegations by dr
ford miss ramirez and miss
swetnick are are wrong
that that is emphatically what i'm
saying
emphatically the swednik thing is a joke
that is a farce
would you like to say more about it no
it was a surreal moment the day was
filled with those at times the hypocrisy
level got
so high you wondered how people in the
room could breathe
there was the oleogenous senator from
new jersey a man who once admitted
molesting a girl in high school
sitting there accusing someone else of
there are dark elements that allow
unconscionable levels
of unacceptable levels of sexual assault
and harassment
you are opening up to open air hurt
and pain that goes on across this
country
as you are speaking
truth that this country needs to
understand
it'd be interesting to hear that the
girl cory booker says he molested speak
her truth in an open hearing we eagerly
await that testimony hopefully soon
then there was the bloodless senator
from connecticut the guy who repeatedly
lied about serving in vietnam
trying his best to impugn another man's
integrity
false in one thing false in everything
meaning
in jury instructions that
we some of us as prosecutors heard many
times
is told the jury that they can
disbelieve
a witness if they find him to be false
in one thing
so the core of why we're here today
really is
credibility the core of why we're here
is an allegation for which the four
witnesses
present have all said it didn't happen
false in one thing false in many things
if you're senator blumenthal can you
even imagine saying something like that
what kind of lack of self-awareness
would it take to say something like that
remarkable underneath all of this though
hung the most obvious question the day
which nobody asked out loud
who did this to christine ford democrats
claim they held these hearings for her
because they cared deeply about her
well-being yet it was democrats who
leaked her name to the press against her
wishes
and dragged her into this maelstrom who
did that
well likely someone in dianne
feinstein's office feinstein claimed she
was not involved
she'd like the presumption of innocence
on that okay so who was it
if you care about christine ford about
all victims of sexual assaults
you'd be very anxious to know maybe we
could have a new investigation into that
republicans can start with immediately
like tomorrow
would democrats participate in an
investigation to find out
who leaked christine ford's name to the
press
probably not they seemed strikingly
uninterested in talking about christine
ford today they rarely asked about her
when judge kavanaugh was on the set
instead they peppered kavanaugh with
questions about his georgetown prep
yearbook
and how much beer he drank in high
school and college here's one of his
responses to that line of questioning
i never sexually assaulted anyone
there is a bright line between drinking
beer
which i gladly do and which i fully
embrace
and sexually assaulting someone which is
a violent crime
if every american who drinks beer or
every american
who drank beer in high school is
suddenly presumed guilty
of sexual assault will be an ugly new
place in this country
i never committed sexual assault
when they weren't demanding answers
about his high school yearbook democrats
stalled for time
they did that by demanding yet another
fbi investigation into kavanaugh
why aren't you also asking the fbi to
investigate these claims
judge kavanaugh will you support an fbi
investigation right now
you could actually just get this
open so that we can talk to these
witnesses and the fbi can do it instead
of us
are you willing to ask the white house
to authorize
the fbi to investigate the claims that
have been made against you
an fbi investigation sounds reasonable
it would be the seventh
fbi investigation that has looked deeply
into brett kavanaugh's personal conduct
he was once staff secretary of the
president united states and at the
highest
level of security clearance this country
gives one that gave him access to
america's nuclear codes he got that
clearance because the fbi spoke at
length to a cross section of everyone
he'd ever met
going back to high school and earlier
and there were no hints of sexual
assaults none
there's nothing left to investigate here
everyone knows that this is a political
tactic and it's disingenuous
why are they doing it well simple
democrats know that if the vote on brett
kavanaugh is held soon
he will be confirmed if it is delayed by
pointless fbi investigations being
demanded by demagogues in bad faith
he will not be confirmed because the
accusations will never end
the incentive to make them is too strong
you'll see more anonymous claims that he
led gang rapes on sailboats in rhode
island or whatever
and this grotesque circus will continue
our ancient standards of justice will
further degrade with the help
of the senate democratic conference but
democrats will retain
power and that is the point is the only
point of
all of this but for now and until and if
that happens no republican senator who
watched brett kavanaugh testify today is
likely to vote against him
those who did would be quickly punished
by voters many viewers at home wept
as they watched kavanaugh speak today
maybe you did as you saw it
those of us who have been falsely
accused of sexual assault by strangers
understood well the feeling of terror
and loneliness that's shown on
kavanaugh's face
prove you didn't do it or everything you
have will be taken from you by
force that's not an easy task for anyone
kavanaugh came as close as a man can
declaring his own name
he didn't get a lot of help from senate
republicans other than lindsey graham
the next time you're falsely accused of
a crime don't ask them for backup
brett kavanaugh did it all himself he
had no choice
as his life collapsed around him he
stood bravely and he spoke clearly
and it's hard to imagine a fiercer test
of a man's character than that